I had elevated EVV, that's M-steed bar virus, it's antimony, so M-steed bar virus, EVV,
antimony, IGG, and my blood test, is there a RIF program for that?
Yes, there are RIF programs, and both the two RIF and the Atelier Robin for M-steed bar virus,
however, so when you do the M-steed bar virus,
blood test, you're going to get, you have the choice of running different antibody panels.
You could do with IGG, IGM, IGA panel, I think, Holy IGG and IGM, for M-steed bar,
so what is the difference? And if I have elevated IGG antibodies for M-steed bar,
does that mean I have M-steed bar? Should I run a RIF program for M-steed bar? I have IGG antibodies.
Most likely not, so when you have, when you're exposed to an antigen,
so when you're exposed to a pathogen of some kind, M-steed bar virus, your body,
how your immune system works is you'll fire a immediate response immune system response,
it's called your TH-1 response, it's trying to kill that pathogen, and then if it can't kill it
because it's very, very virulent, or you have a heavy exposure, then that TH-1 response suppresses
in your TH-2 system virus, or your B cell system virus, and that's the purpose of that is not necessarily
the utility thing, it's creating antibodies, so it creates antibodies against that thing,
if you could think of antibodies as fluorescent tape, that it tapes on that pathogen,
so that now the TH-2 system suppresses in the TH-1 system virus again, and those are your natural
killer cells and macrophages and T cells, and they now can find that pathogen because it's
tagged with this antibody, this fluorescent tape, so now they can find it and adequately kill it,
and there's a benefit of now having circulated fluorescent tape for that pathogen,
so that now maybe it adequately, your body adequately killed it, now you don't have any,
but if we measured your blood, you'd still show positive antibodies,
so if you ever are exposed to that pathogen again, now these antibodies that are circulating in
your bloodstream will tag it immediately, so now you'll maybe just be able to fire a TH-1 response
only, and you'll kill it right away, and you'll never really get sick, that's what having a healthy
immune response is, I was exposed to strep as a young person a lot, I developed a lot of antibodies,
and now my kids have strep, you know, and I don't get sick, why do moms and dads lots of times don't
even get sick? Why, because they have this mom power or something? No, because they have these antibodies
that are already in their system, so that they're, you know, when they are exposed to that strep,
it gets tagged with that fluorescent strep, aka antibody, so that their immune system
fires immediately, kills it, and they don't get sick, quote unquote, they were still sick,
they just didn't have the expression of prolonged illness because their immune system did its job
and destroyed it, because they had circulated antibodies for these things, so really when we say I
have a strong immune system, you're saying I have a lot of circulated antibodies for a lot of
different pathogens, you want to, and this is the danger I've said for decades about taking
your kid to, oh he's got an ear infection, so you're going to run off and get antibiotics here,
he's got a stomach ache, so I'm going to run off and get some antibiotics, so I'm going to take
it, you know, medication to deal with the symptoms instead of allowing them to go through this normal
immune response of a TH1, TH2 response where you actually create antibodies, you want your child to
create antibodies, so that now they won't get sick three weeks from now and another strep goes
around the school, so the strength of a person's immune health is dependent upon the number of
types of antibodies they have for different pathogens, now that being said, how you would measure
whether you have an acute infection of something or not, there's different types of antibodies,
so IGG antibodies are significant to tell a person that they have had exposure to a pathogen, but
most likely don't have current active antigen, so IGG antibodies tell us that you were exposed to
Epstein-Barr virus sometime in your life, you've developed antibodies, these are the IGG antibodies that
will tag if you get exposed to it again tomorrow, but it doesn't mean that you have an active infection,
so there really wouldn't be a need to run a RIF program for it, nor would there be a need to run
out and get some Acidacea or Garlic or whatever you're going to try to do to kill this virus,
IGG, the presence of IGG antibodies typically just tell us that you had a past exposure, now
again, I get a blood test, you look at it with subjective and objective data, correlated with other
things, the person is running a fever, they feel sick, they have all these other symptoms,
maybe they're only showing IGG antibodies, typically though, you'd run an IGG, IGM panel,
and if a person had an active pathogen, they'd have elevated IGM antibodies, so that's really what
you'd look at, so I talk to people all the time that say, oh my gosh, my doctor's treating me for
Epstein mar, oh why, here's the test, they show me the test, they have negative IGM antibodies,
and they have positive IGG antibodies, wrong decision making, clinical decision making there,
that most likely that person has just had past exposure, they do not have occurred infection,
there's no need to treat them, for a current infection of Epstein mar virus, when they show negative
IGM antibodies, it's a positive IGG antibodies, so hopefully that clears that up,